blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman many of you have written to me
asking me to talk about the situation
going on in the country colombia in
south america
and i want to start with that today the
new york times is a good piece
from yesterday updated this morning
summarizing what is going on there there
are now
at least 19 people who have been killed
in what are being called pandemic
related protests
but more specifically the protests are
because there's been a tax
overhaul connected to the pandemic which
has been
proposed that has turned into
anger from colombians about poverty
about inequality about economic
conditions and indeed as the new york
times now
times now reports at least 19 people
have been killed
hundreds have been injured during days
of continued protests in colombia
tens of thousands of people have taken
to the streets to demonstrate
at at least proximally against a tax
overhaul
which uh is as the government claims
necessitated by a financial
whole created by the pandemic
and the president ivan duque
announced he would withdraw the current
proposal
and put together a new plan saying that
this is a necessity for the country
monday the country's finance minister
announced
that he would be resigning but the
protests continue
and the repression continues and now it
is
becoming a larger protest about poverty
in colombia about uh unemployment in
colombia
about inequality in colombia all of
which has been exacerbated by
the pandemic as we've seen in in many
countries
and i've talked a little bit about
what's going on in argentina my country
of birth
incredible anything you can imagine
related to the pandemic has happened in
argentina
officials with vaccines in the trunks of
their car
uh their cars um continued
inflation out of control uh
overwhelmed medical systems strict
lockdowns on paper
that are actually not being followed in
particular by the countries i don't
really want to use the term elite but
upper middle class and many in the
professional class just living as if
there is no pandemic so
there's many examples brazil we have
talked about but this really sort of
taking on a unique shape and character
um in colombia and uh the protests in
part are continuing
because even though the economic
proposal
has been pulled and will be replaced
with something else
the response from the state
has been extremely heavy-handed to put
it lightly and there have been instances
of police abuse captured on video
i'm not going to play them because we'll
just create problems for ourselves
one of one of the unfortunate realities
this is an aside but i think a relevant
one
one of the realities that we live with
in the united states
is that it has for decades
generally speaking not been a
part of protocol to show the violence
that takes place in war
when there is law enforcement repression
and so we in the united states have a
much more sanitized view
of what these via what this violence
looks like around the world
and as a result of that the policy is
that if we include a lot of the
the violent footage it's not just about
demonetization our videos can actually
get blocked all together from
from different platforms and so the
video is out there if you want to go
look for it we won't be including it in
this
um broadcast but there are all sorts of
videos of
police brutality video where young pro
protesters
are seen shot by police
there is an instance of a 17 year old
marcelo agredo who
is a ninth grader sent out to march with
his brother
shot by police died uh after
kicking a police officer going by on a
motorbike
and now we are seeing um a
sort of uh propaganda battle that's also
taking place
between those who say the police and the
military are now
in danger um and they need to be able to
defend themselves a sort of tacit
defense really of the violence against
many of these protesters and of course
those saying
this is a hare-brained idea
from the government in proposing this
economic reform
and then now that very same government
because there has been an outcry against
the
proposal that they made are um
repressing protesters and um
all sorts of video that has been removed
from social media
already and all of the things that we
often associate with these circumstances
in latin america
are taking place now the there are
numbers that have started coming out i
mentioned already
uh tens of thousands of protesters and
certainly hundreds of injuries
the counter narrative is well 540 police
officers have also been hurt
and there have been uh endless instances
of property damage
and uh police say we've identified 17
000
um people who have broken the public
health measures because they were
protesting without wearing masks so
there is always a counter narrative but
the big picture here is that
much like many other countries a uh
a financial shortfall the proposal that
was made economically
would have increased tariffs on all
sorts of everyday goods and services
which would make them even less
affordable for much of the colombian
people
and that caused an outcry and then now
the protesters are get
getting uh knocked knocked around so
we're going to continue following the
situation
all sorts of different uh colombian news
people
and musicians and actors that i follow
on social media have been actively
posting about this and
not enough people in the united states
even know that this is going on at this
point so that's the latest and
these numbers 19 dead there's a reason
why it's
at least 19 dead because in all
likelihood that number is going to go up
tragically so
and we will have more about this maybe
tomorrow maybe friday
and certainly by early next week we are
unfortunately as i've mentioned
getting to the point in the vaccination
campaign here in the united states
where supply is exceeding demand
increasingly by more and more now on the
bonus show today
we are going to talk about the
forthcoming approval of at least the
pfizer vaccine for ages 12 to 15
pfizer already approved 16 plus that
should happen
could be within a week i mean imminently
and that will
add a whole bunch of people to
eligibility
and hopefully we will continue getting
people vaccinated but we are getting to
a point
where the anti-vaccine movement has been
i don't want to call it successful
because it almost sounds like praise but
it has been
effectively destructive in terms of
getting enough people to say i don't
know that i need the vaccine at all or i
don't know that i need it right now
that joe biden has had to announce a
completely new
strategy yesterday a joe biden hoping
for
normalcy to some degree by the fourth of
july holiday in the united states
that is certainly in question as
vaccination continues to slow down
so there has been an overhaul to the
pandemic and joe biden
to the vaccination program and joe biden
announcing yesterday
that this is a new phase the goal is to
at least
partially vaccinate meaning at least the
first shot
for 70 percent of adults by july 4th
and this is you know we talked it wasn't
a major criticism but we
acknowledged that when joe biden was
about to take office and said i want to
vaccinate 100 million within 100 days
we said that's not really ambitious
because we're
well on track for that and then joe
biden said well let's do 200 million in
the first hundred days
and it ended up being about 220 million
i believe shots in the first hundred
days
this is actually ambitious now to say 70
at least one shot by july 4th because
it's continuing to slow down
at first remember we had supply issues
we had distribution problems
that has all been resolved and now the
issue is just telling people hey
you know if you don't want to wear masks
if you don't want to have
capacity limits if you don't want to
have to think about are my kids going to
be in school or not
just go ahead and get yourselves
vaccinated and those most eager to get
vaccinated have done it as many of you
know i had my second shot in late
february
and was considered fully vaccinated by
around you know the first 10 days of
march or something like that
i was extremely eager most people in my
circles are
actually every i can't think of anyone i
know that's not getting vaccinated
personally
and now that has changed and so we need
to figure out
something that can be done part of this
is going to be making it easier for
people to get vaccinated
not only at the beginning remember you
had to find an appointment
and they were difficult to come by and
they were often not conveniently located
a lot of those appointment-based
vaccination clinics have gone to
just show up but still it's not
convenient enough for some people so
now the goal of the biden administration
is for tens of thousands of pharmacies
to not only start doing vaccinations if
they're not
many cvs and walgreens already are but
to just be set up for walk-in
just just show up and get vaccinated
that is the degree to which
supply is now exceeding demand in the
united states
a very different problem than much of
the world much of the world
still has not just supply issues much of
the world has
no supply and we have uh
uh a great situation in terms of supply
in the united states and tons of people
are like nah
i don't know and we've seen uh anti-vac
stuff and vaccine skeptical stuff
from tucker carlson we've seen it we
talked last week about joe rogan's
comments about young people
uh not not needing to get vaccinated if
they are healthy and talking about
you know if you're working out although
there's no connection whatsoever between
working out and how likely it is that
you will get
the virus and be able to spread it so
this is the new plan
walk in any time at tens of thousands of
pharmacies
we will see if the pharmacies go with it
joe biden also announcing a new federal
website as well as a phone number
where you can just call or log on put in
your address your location it'll tell
you what's the closest site
and unfortunately we are at the point
where if it's not really really easy for
people a lot of people just won't do it
so let's hope for
an increase to vaccination numbers those
have declined
as of yesterday more than 106 million
people are what we would call
fully vaccinated and more than 56
of adults about 148 million have
received at least one dose which
by itself provides a significant level
of protection
but not as much as getting both doses so
let's hope for an
increase i think that listen i remain
optimistic because as opportunities to
do things
if you're vaccinated continue to open
um that is going to push more people to
get vaccinated
as um we continue seeing
easier and easier availability i think
we're going to get there and i think we
will beat the variance
although without a doubt at some point a
booster uh tweaked to the variants will
be necessary
but it's a question of well we could
have been looking really really good in
june
versus maybe it's not going to be until
july versus maybe it'll be august or
maybe it will be september
so increasingly opportunities to get
vaccinated but the trump
the the trump administration handing off
significant vaccine skeptical sentiment
to the biden administration
when you say for a year this thing's not
very serious
that makes a lot of people believe they
don't really need a vaccine and that's
exactly what we're dealing with now
tell me if you are seeing anti-vaxx
sentiment
in your community find me on twitter
deepakman we'll take a quick break and
be right back
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of
time of course by the great stephen
hawking this is a book that i have been
aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to
blinkist.com david pakman i've put the
link
right underneath this video grab
yourselves a membership on my website
joinpakman.com if you think that the
daily show is just not enough show for
you and
we've all been in that position i
empathize with that we do an extra show
every day
it's called the bonus show it's just for
our members
and you can sign up at joinpakman.com
facebook has decided to uphold
the ban on donald trump and will
reassess the decision in a few months
this was a decision
we knew had been made a couple of days
ago by facebook's oversight board and it
was set to be announced this morning at
9 00 a.m
and as promised that right around 9am
eastern
the company's decision to suspend donald
trump
on both facebook and instagram was uh
confirmed
and extended for at least a period of
several months
the board did rule that an indefinite
suspension of trump was not appropriate
so that time frame has now been amended
and the board said that they are going
to
re-review this at some period of time
in the relative future it seems as
though
it will happen within six months the
board asked
that facebook complete the review within
six months
and said that maybe some clear policies
could be made to balance public safety
and freedom of expression remember that
originally the ban on donald trump from
facebook
uh different than the one on twitter i
mean every platform had their sort of
own justification
was that the risk to public safety
exceeded facebook's
purported uh desire to allow
freedom of expression and they
made that decision shortly after the
january sixth
trump riot insurrection of the u.s
capitol
this was the most aggressive action
facebook had taken against trump during
his entire four-year term
and mark zuckerberg the facebook ceo
said at the time quote
we believe the risks of allowing the
president to continue to use our service
during this period
are simply too great that decision was
then referred
to the oversight board several weeks
later
because it was such a significant
decision they wanted the board to review
it and
independently judge whether trump should
remain
banned and now indeed they are saying it
will be
i mean i guess we're saying at least six
months
and then it will be reviewed again so
depending on how you want to interpret
this news
trump continues banned and it's a
sledgehammer and cudgel against the free
speech of a former president that's the
way the right
is reacting and we'll have some of those
reaction clips maybe tomorrow depending
on what else is going on maybe not
on the other hand the news seems to be
signaling
that at some point trump is coming back
and my prediction would be
that if it's in six months or five or
seven or whenever
at a certain point the oversight board
at facebook
will determine that at this time
because things have simmered down or
whatever the case may be
at that time the um impetus
for providing a platform for expression
to a former president
will override in this kind of balancing
act the risk to public safety there will
still be a risk to public safety of
allowing trump back on facebook
but it will be overridden uh given the
circumstances at the time now
even though this is the news here is
they have decided
the ban is no longer indefinite they've
announced it is no longer a permanent
ban
fox news couldn't even get the story
correct fox news
went to air this morning with a story
called facebook oversight board bans
trump for life
that's just inaccurate it's the opposite
of the decision
i mean i guess if you think trump won't
live six months i guess in a sense
trump may be banned for his life but
that is not
the story now it's obvious that
if allowed back on the platform donald
trump
would immediately resume using the
platform
to spread corrosive lies and weaponized
disinformation the only question is
whether he should be allowed to do some
of that
because there should be emphasis placed
on allowing a former president to use
these platforms to communicate
even in a situation where someone else a
sort of
mere mortal so to speak you know a
civilian a normal person
would not be allowed to do that and
that's a question that the facebook
board will answer
presumably in about uh six months
now in terms of um
what we're going to get later actually
to donald trump's desire to communicate
directly with the public he has launched
now
this much promoted new communication
platform
it's just a blog and we're going to get
to that later but there is no question
that
you know six months from now we will be
well into the 2022 campaign i know it
sounds insane because
trump still hasn't accepted the results
of 2020 trump still hasn't even accepted
the popular vote results of 2016.
but six months from now we will be
under a year out from the midterms and
so trump's desire to play king maker
and to determine who is a real
republican as far as he's concerned that
is going to be riding very high
in six months which will be early
november of 2021.
so there's no question that we're going
to be hearing more from trump by then
one way or another the question is
whether we will be hearing from him on
facebook for now trump remains
banned but it is no longer an indefinite
ban and we'll have more on that
as needed maybe tomorrow or maybe not
this you have to see this story is an
example of
wasted activism and wasted energy
so many people in this country in many
countries but we're talking about this
one
aren't involved in anything going on
around them
they don't know what's going on they're
checked out
they don't get involved in anything in
their communities whether the
communities are their immediate
surroundings the state federal politics
whatever
some people do get involved but they get
involved
pushing for all of the wrong things and
that's what this is an example of in
yukon oklahoma
a school board meeting was interrupted
by anti-maskers
multiple times each with an outburst
more weaponized than delusional than the
one that came before it
board members in yukon voted to keep
masks on students for the rest of the
semester now how long is that
it's only another 11 days and i'm gonna
get to that in a little bit
and it makes sense to keep students
wearing masks because none of the
students are vaccinated other than the
stray
17 or 18 year old senior at the
elementary school
none of them are vaccinated at the
middle school none of them are
vaccinated and at the high school
almost none of them are vaccinated
there's going to be some flexibility on
the masking policy for the younger
students but 50
anti-masters showed up at this meeting
and shockingly some of them were given
huge rounds of applause
for their anti-mask rants here is one
such woman
screaming that this is not about covid
this is about control
and the crowd goes wild they're cheering
this insanity
[Applause]
people are applauding what appears to be
a demonic possession uh you know
heretofore i did not believe in demonic
possession
but this video is making me second-guess
myself maybe demonic possession is a
thing
this video almost made me believe in
astrology it's so nuts like if someone
came to me
and said david i know it you can't
understand this video but i can
this video is explained because this
woman is a scorpio and scorpios behave
like this
this is so nuts i almost would believe
an astrological explanation because
nothing else is making sense
if you were watching you might have seen
the police start to slowly approach this
woman
as the rant was winding down is there a
silver
lining of some kind here can we say that
hey at least she's showing enthusiasm
about education policy no of course i'm
kidding
this is a tragedy i actually looked at
the yukon
public schools calendar the last day of
school is thursday may 20th
after today they have 11 school days
left and this woman and others are
taking time
out of their days and going crazy about
11 days of masks in school for
unvaccinated children during a global
pandemic
just imagine if they use their activism
and their energy for good instead of
evil like imagine what good these people
could do
if they were fighting for like anything
other than fighting against 11 more days
of masking in school
we would live in a different world if
that energy
was put to something worthwhile and if
you needed any evidence to support
teachers
uh being paid more by the way this video
would be exhibit a because these are the
parents that these teachers are dealing
with now by the way
at one point in the video the woman also
screams that her son is four years old
from what i've read the mask mandate
only partially even applies to the
four-year-old
so she's out there protesting against
just 11 more days of masks
in the fall probably there won't be a
need for masks
assuming vaccination continues and as
far as it applies to her four-year-old
it's part of the day 11 days
of masks it's a tragedy of education
it's a tragedy of culture and it is
horrifying in absolutely every way we
can imagine and when we talk about oh
wow
biden needs a new strategy for
vaccinating people because there's so
many anti-vaxxers
it's the same type of people that would
show up and rant like this
on camera about 11 days of masks it's a
tragedy
it's a real tragedy and we'll have some
more clips from this deranged and hair
brained meeting
on our instagram you can follow the
david pakman show on instagram
at davidpakmanshow you can follow me on
instagram at david.pakman and we'll be
back right after this
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership
is not just a feel-good thing you get
access to the world famous bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21 all one word all lowercase
become a member today okay let's um sort
of uh
circle back for lack of a better term to
some of the stories we've been covering
and are kind of coming to
fortunately natural conclusions now one
is the comedy of errors
of uh the right on social media and
technological incompetence that seems to
plague
so much of the right of course we've
talked about parlor we've talked about
the
uh mike lindell my pillow platform that
failed miserably
we now have another instance of this and
after months of teasing a revolutionary
new social media platform that was going
to be
on the technological vanguard of free
speech and open communication
donald trump has launched his so-called
platform
it's just an outdated looking blog page
with
erratic and unhinged posts from donald
trump
they actually produced a video
announcing
that i don't i can't even really call it
a platform because it's just a blog
um and this is like a campaign ad
for a blog take take a look at this
who supported him in the senate
of history twitter permanently banning
the commander-in-chief's personal
account
with 88 million followers
[Music]
so there it is a donald trump with a
defiant message
that he will not be silenced um
so what is he posting to this blog it's
basically just tweets
uh here's one about mitt romney where
donald trump wrote
so nice to see rhino mitt romney booed
off the stage
at the utah republican state convention
they are among the earliest who have
figured this guy out a stone
cold loser here's another trump blog
about the 2020 election where donald
trump writes quote
the fraudulent presidential election of
2020 will be from this day forth
known as the big lie
a few days ago here is one about the
so-called audit that's happening now
i know it's may of 2021. you might be
thinking
audit what are you talking about the big
audit that
uh he says is going to really reveal
some things in arizona donald trump
writing quote
big victory today in arizona
a highly respected judge has just ruled
that the forensic audit being done by
the arizona state senate can
and will continue over 100 democrat
lawyers were sent to fight against this
audit
the results will be very interesting for
the usa and the world to see
why are the democrats fighting so hard
to hide the facts
i know why and so does everyone else
so this is basically another grift
there's a big
contribute button at the top of the blog
and i guess if you want to donate to
trump at this point
i don't know what you're donating to it
seems maybe 2022 candidates that trump
determines are worthy of his support or
your money you can do that and one of
the funniest things
is that fox news took the bait hook line
and sinker
and they announced this as a platform
publishing an article called quote trump
launches
new communications platform
months after twitter facebook ban
and then the hilarious subtitle
is the space will allow trump
to post comments images
and videos so basically
um it's a blog it's basically blogspot
or blogger installed on donaldj
trump.com the news is trump started a
blog now to be clear
considering the caliber of trump's
audience
this as a quote platform probably
suffices
but you could really make something more
dynamic in 10 minutes with like the
godaddy site builder or
squarespace or something like that but
this may be what trump has to rely on
uh of course we learned today that
donald trump's ban from facebook
is being extended but not indefinitely
it was originally an indefinite ban from
facebook
facebook's advisory board we talked
about this earlier announcing today
that it is no longer indefinite it will
be reviewed again
in about six months but it is going to
go
at least several more months so donald
trump relegated to this now here's my
question for you
um why do you think
that the right is so plagued
with technology issues many of them
hilarious i
completely admit uh if you go back this
is not new
if you go back to the 2008 election
where
in a sense it was the first election
where
the online organizing space was really
prominent
in a presidential race in 2004 with
kerry versus bush
there were newsletters and you were
starting to see but that was very very
early in 2008 obama versus mccain
you really saw a dramatic difference and
i remember being on both of their
newsletters and monitoring both of their
websites
the caliber and effectiveness and and uh
scope and frequency of communication
online from the obama campaign
was just dwarfing what the john mccain
campaign was doing in 2008
and since then we've continued continue
to see this divide
while the ground game particularly
locally
is often much better for republicans
than for democrats we've seen this
continued
gap favoring democrats on the online
organizing and of course
the parlor fiasco is a more recent
phenomenon
uh the my pillow uh
mike lindell frank speech disaster
is another one um the uh
so so i don't what do you think it is
is it that um i don't know is it
something about
who are the targets of the communication
and that's why the right is using
antiquated websites and relying on
facebook because they're trying to reach
disproportionately older people i don't
know what the answer is but i'd be
curious to know your thoughts as to what
explains what is now almost 15 years
really
of significant and persistent
disadvantage for the right
when it comes to online organizing we've
been following the situation with donald
trump's former personal attorney
rudy giuliani whose home in office were
raided by the fbi last week
now while some claimed that this was
clearly
the work of joe biden the real reason
that it took this long
for rudy to get raided is that trump
appointees to the justice department
blocked the warrants while donald trump
was still president
so rudy gave an interview to tucker
carlson last week it was a complete
disaster
rudy tried again this week to exonerate
himself on the sean hannity program and
it didn't go any better and in fact
in fact it raised new questions about
rudy giuliani's possible wrongdoing this
is
a very common trend we see on the rights
accused of something or suspected of
something they do
some kind of public-facing event to
claim innocence
and it raises more questions about all
of the things they
may be guilty of so let's jump right
into the first clip rudy assuring us
that he is definitely absolutely
completely not a russian agent my
reaction is the headline of the
washington post
giuliani briefed on russian connection
they've been trying to make me a russian
agent for about three years
which is totally nut i'm probably the
biggest anti-communist he ever met
uh there's no way that i'm a russian age
or anybody else's agent i was a lawyer
who was representing a client who was
innocent the biggest burden a lawyer can
have is to represent an innocent man
and i did it damn well and and i have
exposed
that our president is one of the biggest
criminals in the history of the country
thank you a real hero that rudy giuliani
and definitely not a russian agent okay
then rudy continues by alleging that
this entire investigation into him which
remember
started during trump's administration
and has
nothing to do with joe biden is all
concocted
to destroy his credibility and this is i
mean
this is totally done because
they want to destroy my credibility
because i have that entire hard drive
i have the whole thing i put it out to
the
imagine being the guy who flew around
the country making bogus election claims
who thought that melissa carone would be
a star witness in michigan
who loudly farted relentlessly just bomb
after palm through a hearing in whatever
state
that took place in got covered likely
spread covered
and you think they need this to
discredit you it is just
out of this world delusional and then to
end the interview
rudy coming back after all this trouble
with his bogus election claims claiming
he has all the evidence
and it's on it's on podcast episodes one
through eight if you can believe it
persecuted because i brought it out i
have it and you're saying that there is
more illegal activity that we haven't
heard about i want to i want to ask a
quick last question you're saying that
there is other stuff we will learn
likely in the future that yes if you if
if yes sir if you would like to if you
would like to
get a preview go to my early podcast
one through eight where i put the
evidence out
i'll give you an example there is a
clear money laundering violation
involving the biden family it's on paper
from
uh from ukraine to latvia to cyprus
to a hidden bank account last question i
would only
i would keep you on longer if i had the
time that's right
he's being investigated for his
involvement with the ukraine fiasco
for his lobbying activities while
serving as the
personal attorney to a sitting president
of the united states but
none of that is the real story the real
story is the hunter biden
cypriot money money laundering story
which you can learn about in rudy's
podcast episodes one through eight
during which he also advertises cigars
can you imagine so if you were
unsure whether rudy seemed guilty before
this interview
i don't think this interview helps at
all i come away from this interview
thinking wow there's even
more things that we should be
investigating
when it comes to rudy giuliani not
enough attention is being made to all of
the ways in which rudy giuliani may be
guilty of wrongdoing
i don't even know for whose benefit rudy
is doing these interviews at this point
certainly they aren't helping his actual
legal case
if he's trying to try this in the court
of public opinion
i don't think it's helping that either
so my question to you
what is the point of all this why is
rudy doing these interviews and what
exactly is he trying to achieve
let me know what you think and we'll
follow up about it later this week
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him okay this you have to see
um in the aftermath
of the last presidency some media
outlets have continued
to interview the children of the former
guy
really his two adult sons donald trump
jr and occasionally eric trump
eric trump is nowhere near as
he's nowhere near as good as don jr
during these tv appearances
and he appeared on the greg kelly
newsmax show
and delivered a bizarre nearly two
minute word salad that truly rivals
anything we've heard from donald trump
himself
apparently the apple really doesn't fall
far from the tree
and i challenge you to tell me what on
earth is eric trump talking about the
headline at the bottom of the screen
presumably the topic of the interview is
what does joe biden do
in a day now without even seeing what
eric trump says
it's already funny because donald trump
played golf on something like the 18 or
19
of the days of his presidency he
essentially did no real work during the
last six to eight months of that
presidency
but somehow now the story is what
exactly is joe biden doing
put that aside watch this and i
challenge you
tell me what eric trump is even talking
about see if you can figure it out well
i mean in my whole life greg i've seen
it right i mean when i was uh when i was
a kid he called me six o'clock in the
morning honey are you up
good you better be up you know he'd call
me at 11 o'clock at night again test me
i mean my father's just a guy who's
never stopped his entire life has been
like that whether it's in business no
matter what he sets his you know mind to
um you know the apprentice etc etc the
presidency the way he campaigned i mean
there's never been a person in political
history that's campaigned as hard as my
father has and frankly as hard as our
our family did and you know when you saw
biden i was talking about obviously you
know by not leaving his basement in
wilmington delaware right there but
you know you see these farmers i go all
over the country you'd be with coal
miners you'd be with farmers you'd be
with you know first responders um you
know cops
just great americans that own small
businesses etc right you know these
people are up at five o'clock in the
morning
and they don't come back sometimes until
midnight you know from work and
sometimes they're working two and three
jobs and
you know you're the president of the
united states i mean you should set an
example and the one thing that no one
could ever say about my father as as as
crazy as the media was right
there's no person in the media as much
hatred as there often was for my father
who wouldn't say that he was the hardest
working president this country has ever
had and
okay so before we get to what i'm sure
is just a riveting and compelling
story from eric trump i guess first
eric trump is talking about how hard his
dad worked when he was president
and then he's talking about how hard
some farmers work
and it's all meant to make joe biden
look bad
is that the gist of this even the hosts
starting to look look a little bit
confused
let's now listen to eric trump's
anecdote
and i'm sure it's just endlessly
inspirational and greg just a kind of
funny little anecdote i remember you
know so many different people from new
york times et cetera they'd be following
him rally at a rally at a rally
these are 25 year olds they would be
sleeping in a backpack
you know in in the back of an auditorium
after the sixth rally with three red
bulls three empty red bulls next to them
totally passed out
they couldn't keep up with him yet you
know he's delivering
hours and hours of speeches to different
crowds where he has to keep such
mojo such energy going the entire time
such passion going i mean he would
literally run these young kids who were
following him around the press pool he
would run them into the ground and uh
you know that's what this country needs
and uh you know you look at around the
world at the world leaders
you know do we think putin has energy do
we think um you know
go down the list i mean these guys have
you know men and women have tremendous
work ethic
it's funny how the first guy he thinks
of to praise
for his energy is vladimir putin like
down to
every detail this is just hilarious and
there's a certain
disconnect from reality where eric trump
says listen
for all the things that were said about
my dad
no one could say that he didn't work
hard
and and the opposite is true trump
golfed a historic amount more than any
other president
trump had endless so-called executive
time on his schedule which just means
kind of hanging around watching tv hours
and hours every single day
trump often wouldn't come down to the
oval office to even ostensibly start
working until 10 11
noon even trump stopped even pretending
to do work
for the final six to eight months of his
presidency
and towards the end of that they weren't
even publishing a schedule they were
simply putting out
every day a note that said the president
will work from early in the morning
until late in the evening
he will have many phone calls and many
meetings like they weren't even
pretending
to claim that donald trump was working
towards the end
it's the opposite of what eric trump
says was true about donald trump's
work ethic now one other thing eric's
big example
of trump's hard work is trump did lots
of rallies
this actually relates to something
significant
doing rallies isn't work it's not being
the president and in fact
donald trump was so obsessed with
getting back to rallies even during the
pandemic
that it was part of the reason he wasn't
doing any real work during the last half
year
of his presidency but that's what they
all see
as doing work and as being busy and
there's just a fundamental
misunderstanding
a lack of understanding as to what it is
a president should or could even
uh be doing and uh then pray you know
praising putin at the end
is just sort of the cherry on top i
don't know why eric keeps doing
interviews don jr
says disastrous crazy and dishonest
things
but he's better on tv eric just seems
confused and half of what he says
is completely unintelligible you all may
know
that i am not big on talking about
wokeness like i don't use the term
seriously
i don't say whoa that when when i want
to say someone's re
really politically and culturally aware
i talk about issues and i evaluate ideas
individually i don't say
that that person's really woke i don't
really care about whether one has a
certain package of beliefs to qualify as
woke
but as much as the wochists talk about
being woke
and at this point i don't know that
anybody's really doing it other than
than
sort of ironically the right wing has
developed a real obsession
with wokeness as some kind of dangerous
subculture
of some kind and they love filling air
time
with it but it's gotten so stupid
because
again most of the left isn't even
talking about being woke in a serious
way anymore some do
it's not a really big thing so here is a
painfully cringe-inducing news max
segment
where a guest quizzes uh the two hosts
on their wokeness and everything about
this sent
chills down my spine for how cringy it
is now
first as a mere technical thing the
entire segment
is confusing because the quiz answers
are put on screen and they're numbered
one two and three
but the guy running the quiz keeps
talking about options a b
and c like it doesn't match up down to
every detail it's all so stupid and
nonsensical but let's get into this and
see if we can learn anything about how
the right
sees supposed wokeness now is this a
comedy segment
i don't know i don't think so because
newsmax
i don't think has any comedy shows but
with the gut-felt show on fox now
um completely distorting what is and
isn't considered comedy
you never really can tell alright so
let's get into the first segment and i
think that this is not comedy let's look
when i find out how woke both of you are
especially with a really really short
quiz so let's kind of get to it very
quickly and
let's see how woke both of you are so
number one
how do you feel about man spreading a
it's a real problem
b people should give each other space or
c it's completely nonsense
what do you say heather it's complete
it's more than complete nonsense
it's incomplete nonsense it makes no
sense
okay now my answer on that is what they
would call b
or i guess number two people should give
each other space
uh regardless of gender and um
i i you know gender i find myself
extremely annoyed by people who crowd me
when it's not necessary and i don't care
about gender when i was just in aruba
for uh david pakman show spring break in
march
fully vaccinated of course um i was
waiting at a
restaurant outdoors i did all outdoor
and
i was wearing my mask because the rules
in aruba are
when you approach a restaurant and when
you're being brought to your table even
if the table is outdoors you just wear
your mask and i'm going to do it those
are the rules if i want to travel at
this time i follow the rules okay
so i'm wearing my mask and i'm standing
standing next to my girlfriend
and i really just i looked at the guy
and i knew this was going to be annoying
american guy with no mask he has the
mask over one
ear and it's hanging like it's just
hooked onto one ear
comes and stands right behind me now
when i say right behind me you might say
david you're exaggerating
no no no this guy was so close that when
i did a half turn
just to look at him and sort of say dude
back back uh btfo
just doing a half turn made it so that
my elbow goes right into this guy's
chest
and i just turn and look at this guy and
he backs up maybe six inches
that has nothing to do with gender i
don't care
what bathroom anyone's in i just
give people space i'm sorry whether it's
in a bathroom or man spreading or
whatever
um just give people space that's my view
let's continue on to the second question
so number two should transgender people
be allowed to use the bathroom
of their choosing a i don't feel
comfortable with that b
make all bathrooms gender neutral or a c
of course
i'll say number one i don't want to know
that much about you i just want to go in
and use the men's room
okay okay now i actually start to get
the sense here
that even the hosts are are sort of
virtue signaling and what i mean by that
is
they seem to be picking the answers that
they believe
are the correct anti-woke answers
for the newsmax audience like i have a
hard time
imagining that they really care too much
about which bathrooms people use now i'm
a number two
and three on that or you might call it
bnc
i don't care what bathroom people use i
would like to see
gender-neutral bathrooms singles i guess
we call them
really common in europe that that's
where i'm at let's keep going
okay number three should women be
allowed
combat roles in the military a yes women
are equal to men
b but held the same house the same
standards as men or c
no women are weaker i say number two
yeah i'd go with two as long as you're
held to the same stance yeah
same standards but you can if you can do
the job do the job
well um i now i agree with them here i'm
a two on that or b
and that's been my position on a lot of
these things firefighting
military stuff whatever if there's a
reason why
in the job you need to drag 150 pounds
100 yards in under a minute or whatever
then if you can do it you should be
qualified for the job period that is my
view
um i don't think that makes me anti-woke
it might make them more woke than they
even want to believe
all right last segment i was surprised
about the quiz here in a moment number
four should a baker
be forced to make a wedding cake for a
gay couple even though
that they don't agree with gay marriage
a yes b
maybe or c no uh
let's see oh i'm it's easy no i mean
they can find somebody else to make it
i mean no and i know that that disagrees
with
with the law right now there are people
paying fines
uh you know for it but no they shouldn't
be forced
yeah it's a private enterprise for
goodness sake absolutely that's what i
was going to say for sure
are you cringing yet the female host
actually seemed unsure what she was
supposed to say there
so she lets the guy answer and then
jumps in with yeah yeah that's what i
was that's what i was going to say
now the wording of that is the wording
that the right loves
they love saying should the anti-gay
baker
be forced to make a wedding cake for gay
people like a slave
almost and in fact rand paul has talked
about single payer would make doctors
like
slaves that's not the right framing
that's like saying should a racist baker
be forced
to make a cake for a black couple even
if they don't like black people
that's not the right framing the framing
is should it be legal
to discriminate against people on the
basis of race
or on the basis of sexual orientation
that's a more accurate framing they love
that framing that they just gave
it's not the right framing uh okay and
then here's the wrap up
okay all right last but not least do you
think young children
should be given the choice to become
transgendered and receive hormone
treatments a
yes it's their body their choice b wait
until they're adults or
c no no yeah i go wait until you're an
adult make whatever decision you want
but that's ludicrous for kids that
they're still developing
psychologically and mentally heather
bob i have to tell you you know what
this is probably one quiz
you're going to be ecstatic about
failing because you are the least woke
people
probably walking so you've got an f on
this this is truly painful to watch
they don't even realize or really
understand
what being woke is or how the quiz works
or really anything and again a bogus
question it's not about
children having the choice to become
trans trans just means
you have a sense of personal identity
and gender that doesn't match your birth
sex biologically you can't control
whether a kid
is trans that's something that they feel
inside the question is about whether
they should be allowed to do certain
things to have their gender identity
match their sex they don't even know
what it means to be trans
and the question as is maybe not
surprising to you
portrays a total lack of understanding
of what these issues even are
so there's the quiz i don't know who
passed or who failed or whatever but a
very very painful segment to watch on
newsmax
and it's hard to imagine that uh that is
compelling watching
for too many people that are watching it
unironically we have a voicemail number
and that number is 2192 david p
earlier this week i mentioned something
that seems to be of great interest to
some in the audience i mentioned
there are always dips in viewership for
news and politics after any presidential
election and indeed
we saw that in january and february and
news networks are reporting the same
things cnn and others ratings are very
very low for news in general
some of it is trump was entertaining
some of it is there's fatigue etc but
somehow for some reason much of our
viewership
has already recovered in march and april
and we were not expecting viewership to
recover until much later in the year
why is it i got a ton of voicemails from
people weighing in on this
let's take a listen to some of them hi
david this is
zachary from delaware um i do it uh
on monday and asked a question about
viewership falling off at the beginning
of the year and
you know i think i'd get a little
insight like i had kind of stopped
watching all political things for a
couple months because fights have been
you know inaugurated everything was
going smooth and
honestly after the election and four
years of trump it was just a bit of
burnout
uh but now you know and now i feel
comfortable enough you know
dipping my toes back into getting
information it's just she kind of took a
break
and i think a lot of people did you know
there was four years of non-stop
you know living on the edge and just
knowing that things were going okay and
there was an adult there
was enough for me to just let myself
kind of decompress
and then uh now again there's more
issues coming up and you know as the
jobs bill and the infrastructure bills
are coming out there's more information
i want so i want to get back plugged
back in but
you know the uh okay so i think we get
the picture the idea being that yes
the the reasons for the drop-off for
this viewer were the ones
that we we talk about burnout and taking
a break but
that some of what's going on politically
has made them jump back in more quickly
all right that's one possibility here's
another
uh take hi david i
watched your video where you were
wondering why people came
back after the december viewing of their
videos that
you know podcasts and the such had
dropped off
and viewers returned well
the reason i have is i find you
the most unbiased reviewer of
politics right now wow that you give a
fair review you admit when you're wrong
you know no drama basically
which is refreshing to see on youtube
um maybe not everything you report might
be totally true
only but you are reporting the facts
as you know it that i appreciate
absolutely okay so that caller saying
there's something about
she just likes this show and that's why
she's back more quickly
here's one last opinion as to why we
might have had a
much shorter post-election dip than in
some years
hi david my name is michelle and i'm
from albany new york
um i was just watching you on youtube
and decided to
drop you a voicemail um because you were
talking about
why um you're still seeing
uh quite a few viewers on your show even
though there might have been a dip
um after donald trump lost and i so i
just wanted to say why i
watch you i actually started watching
you not long after the
january sixth insurrection right i
actually
originally voted for donald trump and i
wish i could go back and change
that out even though he lost um because
i started to become
disgusted with him after the way he
didn't handle the insurrection
and i honestly i found you i stumbled
upon you
on youtube and i enjoyed the way you
explained things
that i didn't really understand i
appreciated the fact that you take your
time when you're talking
that someone like me i need that because
i'm
trying to understand uh more
about politics so this one's interesting
because
this is someone who just entered the
fray of progressive online media
after the election and has come over
from from the other side so three
different explanations
i think what we're kind of learning is
the reason why
we've recovered from the post-election
dip so quickly
uh has a lot of different answers that
are different for different people but
we're glad that it's going on for sure
we have a great bonus show for you today
we will talk about what is going on with
house republicans
uh and liz cheney because the the drama
continues
the supreme court will weigh in on the
crack cocaine
sentencing disparity if you don't know
about this issue it's quite an issue
and pfizer says we soon will have
approval
of their covet vaccine for those age 12
to 15.
we will discuss those stories and more
on today's bonus show
don't miss it get instant access by
signing up right now there's no reason
to wait
at join pacman.com see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman